strolls are the bad guys and you're a  Kree a race of noble boys noble warrior  heroes we found you we made you one of  us  this war is just the beginning  I'm not going to fight your war  I'm gonna end it  so scrolls are the bad guys  and you're a Cree a race of noble  warriors heroes noble warrior heroes  [Music]  your life began the day it nearly ended  we found you with no memory we made you  one of us so you could live longer  stronger superior  you were reborn  I keep having these memories something  in my past is the key to all of this  you're not a black thing we'll see  that's a yes or no question yes  [Music]  would you like to know  what you really are  I think I had a life here  what are you telling me  you've come a long way  but you know as strong as you think  [Music]  the slaw is just the beginning  I'm not going to fight your war  I'm gonna end it  [Music]  [Music]  I'm pseudo cute as low thing are you  what's your name  [Music]